i think you're on
mute i can't see if you're talking
you're definitely
mute yeah can you see my slides
we can okay all right
uh i'm sorry okay i'm trying to get rid
of this
all right so um so this theme
is um at the intersection so it's a
pretty broad theme where there's really
some concrete projects around sampling
and concrete projects around
optimization
and i need to actually tell you about
the connections between them so i'm a
little i was a little torn between
uh you know introductory talk or really
going to an overview of various
questions
and i decided to stay um to present
a fairly introductory talk on on that
what i think is probably one of the most
uh
fascinating aspects of the interface
between sampling and optimization
all right so um just to present the team
that's working on this so uh it's a
team uh four people at mit for people at
berkeley and
francesco rabona at boston uh
so the objective of this team is to uh
so
i'm sorry uh if you're advancing the
slides it's not showing up for us
oh i see um
let's see
maybe this bring your shared window to
the front
oh i know what i need to do okay sorry
about that
let me share um
no i don't think i know how to do this
all right let me
um
that's probably the safest one okay
so can you see the slides now okay good
all right so uh the team
uh has uh as i said four four uh uh
researchers from mit from from berkeley
and francesco from
from boston so the objective of this uh
of this uh um theme is to develop a
combined perspective
uh that allows us to make progress both
on optimization and sapling and there
are some
really two-way connections between the
two there's also some interesting
connections to pdes which i will
uh not mention in this talk and actually
i will mostly mention
uh how to use optimization techniques uh
to advance
uh uh our understanding of sampling all
right so
what is sampling well sampling is
actually becoming something which is
uh uh pretty topical especially thanks
to uh websites such as this person that
does not exist and you go there
and you have like some beautiful
pictures that are generated by
gans or variational auto encoders and
you press and you keep on getting
some very realistic photos uh some look
less realistic than others
and uh and then what you get is uh
a way to generate new data but of course
this is not a new question right so of
course
sampling is a central question in
bayesian statistics actually
perhaps the most central uh uh when you
think about mcmc there's a huge amount
of research uh
interested in assembling especially from
high dimensional
distributions and it arises in a variety
of examples of applications one is
online algorithms that was mentioned by
mike where you're trying to explore and
you need to sample your space in an
efficient manner to explore this
so i'm going to look at a very stylized
problem around sampling i'm certainly
not going to be sampling faces i'm going
to sample from
a density and the standard setup in um
bayesian statistics is that you know
your density up to
normalizing constant this is your
posterior the product of your prior
and your likelihood and you don't know
typically what generalizing constant
then here
we'll focus on the low concave density
where i can always uh write
pi as e to the minus v for some convex v
okay
and a standard tool to uh
sample from this a central tool is this
launchville diffusion
and the launchboard diffusion is a
stochastic differential equation which
is given in this frame here
and it's just dxt minus grad v so you
have a drift term which
is given by the negative gradient of v
so it's pushing
your uh particles towards the minimum of
v
and then you have a stochastic term
square root two uh a d brown
motion at t so this is just something
that gives you if you didn't have this
part you would just go to the minimum
of a v and you want to actually have a
sample
with some entropy in there
and it's well known this is a standard
probabilistic result that this has the
right stationary distribution which has
density pi
of course in practice we don't implement
this continuous time
stochastic differential equation what we
do is we discretize
and a lot of work goes into
understanding what level of
discretization we should be using so
this formula down there
is telling you that you hear you have a
step size h and finding the right h is
still very much an active area of
research
which i will uh gloss on throughout this
talk
[Music]
okay so what is the connection with
sampling and optimization well if you
look at the stochastic differential
equation you look just at the first part
so you forget
the brown motion as i said this is just
a gradient flow and it's trying to
minimize this v
so clearly there is an optimization
ingredient here okay
this is a basic gradient flow and of
course you add a stochastic term
but you know who is afraid of stochastic
optimization nowadays stochastic
gradient descent
is a a very popular algorithm
and so this is a very standard uh
connection between sampling and
optimization and in fact uh
this uh perspective is what has driven
dalai leon
in 2014 to essentially revive the
understanding of launchman
algorithms and by saying well we have a
lot of well-developed techniques to
analyze gradient descent or stochastic
grain descent
i can open uh lecture notes from nest
raf or
from bubeck and and and just uh apply
those techniques and that's very much
what he did and uh the conditions were
weakened later on by idioms okay so
a fruitful perspective but almost a a
very
obvious connection between optimization
and sampling here
so the the geometric picture i want you
to see here in geometric is the first uh
name of this theme is
is this okay so here we want to think of
our
our particle xt as moving as a
trajectory on our d
okay so we have this space of of
particles xt lives on our d and it
follows this
you know sort of a brownian sorry
gradient flow with
some stochastic drift so it kind of
looks like a brown motion but it's going
down okay
so you're on a flat space and you have
something that's moving around
but in fact i argue that uh what i would
like to emphasize today
is this second taken optimization where
we're not thinking about how
what the geometry of the trajectory of
xd is but the geometry of the law of xds
all right so xt has some probability
distribution that evolves over time
and you're trying to understand what is
how is this thing changing
over time okay and so i'm going to put
this and i have a curve
of of trajectories that starts at mu 0
goes to mu infinity we know that mu
infinity is the one that has the right
density pi and we'd like to understand
this curve and if we can understand this
curve how fast
it converges then we can actually
understand uh
the rate of convergence of the launch
value fusion for example okay
but to understand this i need to
understand what space am i even showing
here so there's this curve space it's a
space of probability distribution it
will be curved so there's many spaces of
frequency distributions we can think of
but we want to think about the right one
for this problem and this right one will
be
the wasserstein space affordability
distribution which is a space
that arises using tools from optimal
transport
so let's open a brief parenthesis on
optimal transport
and so probably by now everybody's seen
optimal transport but let me remind you
uh what it is so
the idea of optimal transport is that
you have a pile of dirt so when most
introduced that
he talked about deble which is a pile of
dirt and you're trying to fill
a ditch somewhere and it's called the
humble and
he was trying to minimize the amount of
of of work the amount of
of distance that uh the dirt had to
travel to fill those gaps okay
so what he's trying to do is to try to
find it what's called a transport map
which is a valid way of
of moving the the dirt from one pile to
the ditch
and uh and uh also among all possible
ways to do this he was trying to find
the one that would minimize the amount
of work
okay so those maps those valley
transport maps
so we're going to think of the pale of
dirt mu as uh uh sorry the pile of dirt
the debris as being a probability
distribution so
volume one and the the the homebrew of
course it has to fit the dirt so it's
gonna also have
volume one and we'll call it new so
you'll have two probability
distributions
and having a valid transport map
something that really takes
the pilot and put it in a ditch is uh uh
so-called a transport map
in probabilistic terms we say that t
pushes mu to new
and this where this little hashtag
notation is doing just that
okay so this is just saying that if x
has distribution mu
then t of x has distribution nu
and so many ways to do this and what
moles
advocated was to take the one that
minimizes the
expected amount of of of uh of work
uh that you need to travel okay so what
is this amount of work well
you look at the distance between x and
where it goes t of x okay so you take
the difference between those two
take the squared norm and then this is a
random quantity you average it over all
possible starting point
x distributed according to mu so that's
the distance the x
the average square distance traveled by
a a grain of sand say coming from
the pale of dirt mu and now among all
possible
ways to travel you're trying to find the
one that minimizes overall valid ones
okay so it turns out that this uh uh
this quantity here so it's homogeneous
to to a square
uh and uh it turns out that uh this
thing is actually a square distance okay
so this is a square distance it's the
minimum here exists and is unique if
mu has a density which will be the case
because we're talking about a diffusion
so as soon as time is
strictly positive you are completely
diffused and so
uh uh for the example of the launch
value fusion all mutes for positive t
are uh diffuse and um
and now i have this thing which defines
the square wasserstein distance w2
squared between mu and u
okay so it's not trivial that this is a
a square distance but
but it is and uh so it's in fact the two
western distance because of this
power two over there and uh you could
take a power p and that would give you
the vassar's time p but
here for this talk we only care about
vassar's time two
and it gives you a distance not over all
probability distributions like let's say
the
total variation would uh it's giving you
only uh on those for which there is a
finite second moment okay you need to be
able to talk about the expectation of
the square
but that's essentially uh the the
limitation here okay so okay i just
mentioned
another distance uh total variation and
you probably know other ones there's
many distances there's if you have a
density you could talk about the l2
distance or
one distance between your densities
there's many ways to think about
distance between parabola distribution
this one seems complicated and the
question is why would you do this
so let's just look at the geometry that
it induces okay so here i
look uh so the way you think about the
geometry between distance between
probability distributions by looking at
midpoints okay so
if i take mu and nu okay so i have to
the left i have mu
and to the right have new and i'm
interested in wanting what is the
average in l2 so that would be the
average of the two densities so that's a
mixture the density of the mixture
between those two distributions well
it's really just one half of the first
function plus one half of the second
function
so you see those two bumps uh one
corresponding to each of them with with
weight one half each
and what vasserstein does so of course
you can vary the weight
and what vasserstein does is that it
actually essentially
puts a midpoint which has which is
slowly def
uh moving the mass from where the mass
of mu is to the mass of
nu is but on the on the x-axis rather
than on the y-axis
okay and and this curve that i'm showing
you is the geodesic all right so that's
basically
the space of convex combinations between
mu and mu in that sense
and uh and that defines an average in
investors time space
so what is this geodesic well there's
actually a very simple form for it so
this geodesic is a point so it's going
to be a space of
is the equivalent of straight lines in
this curve space a shortest path
and uh um it's essentially so it's going
to be a distribution and the
distribution that's
at time t on this say unit speed
geodesic that goes from time 0 to 1
at time 0 is at a mu and at time 1 is at
nu
is the distribution of this context
combination of x and its transported
version
where t here is the optimal transport
map that arises
from uh uh the definition of uh uh
vasserstein all right so if you look at
the first line i say that wasserstein
squared is the expectation of this
specific transport map so that's the
argument
and uh now what i do is that i sample x
i look at where it goes t of x
and i take the convex combination
between the two and uh
and that gives me uh the distribution
along the geodesic
okay so we understand very well those
geodesics so now we have a space it's a
geodesic space
we have a space where uh not only is it
a metric space where we have a distance
but we can also define geodesics between
those points okay
so we start having more and more
structure on the space of parabola
distributions
what we're missing now is a differential
structure i would like to be able to
take derivatives and this thing
is infinite dimensional it's actually
not homogeneous at all so i would like
to say somehow that it's a romanian
manifold
but it really is not okay it's missing a
lot of the the properties you would like
from romanian manifold
but it turns out that uh there's
something that that was invented by
felix auto
called uh now called auto calculus which
is a way to define and
at first it was done formally and later
on it was made uh uh
completely rigorous by uh uh uh mostly
by the work of ambrosio
uh gili and savari uh in their book
where where uh on grading flows where
you can define notions of gradients and
define an entire differential structure
which
essentially allows you to manipulate um
the vaserstine space of probability
distributions equipped with the massage
time distance
as if it was a romanian manifold and so
of course the thing for having a
differential structure you need to know
what velocity vectors are okay so
i have this curve it goes from mu to nu
at unit speed
that's what it is and if i'm allowed if
i'm able to define a tangent vector
that tells me what the velocity at
initial point is then i'm golden i
actually can define it everywhere
and here the velocity is precisely given
by the transport map between mu and u
minus the identity that's what my
velocity is and that's what's going to
play the role
of velocities and that's why i need to
have uh um
uh um densities uh
because then the transport otherwise the
transport might does not does not exist
and actually most of the work in
defining this differential structure
is to extend it beyond the case where
you don't have when
when you're at points where there's no
density
so now that i have this differential
structure i can start talking about
derivatives and gradient descent and
gradient flows
so uh so this this book sometimes called
the bible
uh by ambrose savara is telling you
everything you want to know about
gradient flows on uh
uh metric spaces actually geodesic
spaces and and and more
precisely this western space and what it
does is okay let me give you a
functional on the space of probability
measures okay so you give me a
probability measures i'm going to spit a
real number
f of mu and uh here i gave you three
examples of such
measures there's this linear form
integral v d
mu there's the kl divergence between mu
and u or the chi-square divergence
you can think of of many of them and for
those i would like to be able to define
what is the gradient of this functional
so meaning i would like to know how this
functional behaves when i perturb mu a
little bit on this vassarstein space
and this notion of of uh gradient is of
course
very much tied to the the the distance
that i equipped the space of news with
and you have explicit forms for what it
is for these three examples and you know
you there's actually
uh there's an entire calculus which is
in place that allows you to compute this
and it's important to be able to do it
with several of them
and what it gives you is a a way to
define a gradient descent so here i'm
using completely non-standard
terminology but i would like to
emphasize the fact that
i would like to say that i have this
curve of probability measures mu t
and i would like to tell you how it
evolves all right so this mu dot t you
really should think of it as the
velocity
of mu of a curve mu t
uh uh when i move from t to dt okay so
there's a velocity for each curve
and this will just be minus the gradient
of a functional it's of course here the
vosterstein gradient
and if you look at those three examples
what is the nature
of the wasserstein gradient well look at
the first one it's grad
v dot okay so it's basically a a
um sorry a vector field
on rd all right so grad v at x for
example just gives me a vector at
x and so that gives me a gradient field
a vector field everywhere okay
and so the grad of f gives me a vector
field
uh and and the way you want to read this
is by saying that if i think of a
particle
x t which is uh distributed according to
mu t
the way it evolves so the the dot that
you see here when you see x t dot is the
real one so that's the derivative of x t
in our d so the way it evolves is by
minus this uh velocity field
uh uh grad uh uh w of f
and ut when i apply this at the point xt
okay so what i'm really showing is so
that's the way to implement this
gradient field
uh this uh this uh gradient flow by
thinking at the particle level
but but the important part is to think
of it as really
describing a trajectory in the space of
probability measures
so now that i have this uh this uh
gradient flow perspective
i can see what happens if i look at
specific functionals okay
so here for example let's look at the
functional which is the kl between mu
and nu
and very soon i will take nu to be the
distribution that has density pi
as i started from and so if i plug it in
so i just told you in the previous slide
that the gradient
of the kl is grad log d mu t over d nu
okay and now what is d mu t over dnu
well i uh sorry log of this i have the
grad log d mu t
i cannot really do much about it but
then the d nu
is nu is e to the minus v as a density
so when i take log of this
i get v and and so i i'm looking at now
grad v okay so i have mu t which looks
like minus grad v
uh uh which which moves like minus grad
v
and then there's this extra term minus
grad log d mu
okay so now the way you want to think of
this
again this is really at the particle
level so what i'm really doing is that
if i have a particles look at the last
line here
if i'm looking at x t which follows mu t
then after a little bit of time say t
plus dt or t
plus h i'm moving i'm close to xt and
the way i've moved is by moving
in the direction of grad v and also in
the direction of grad log d mu t
okay so now this is almost our gradient
descent except that uh or stochastic
gradient descent just like we had in the
discretization of launch vehicle
except that in launchpad we had this
gaussian term that was just like pure
gaussian noise that slapped onto this
and here we're looking at this weird
thing which is grad log of the density
at the
current time and the beauty of
of of this uh theory is this uh uh
almost i'd say transformative work by
jordan kindellero and otto in 98
which showed that in fact as h goes to
zero this converges
to the launchbound diffusion all right
so you have this deterministic maps
right everything here is deterministic
it's saying move xt plus h is x t minus
so here
grad v is deterministic grad log d mu t
is deterministic
everything's moving deterministically
and what it says is that the curve that
you will get by doing this deterministic
moves
that follow this gradient flow of the kl
is the same as what you would get if you
were to run this launch valid fusion
so let's pause for a second and try to
understand what's happening here
we showed that when i run this launch
round diffusion
i'm going to converge to pi but what
it's really telling me what this jko
picture is telling me is that in fact
what i'm doing is this gradient flow
so i'm doing steepest descent on the kl
divergence which of course at the
minimum
will go down to pi right because i i
need to have kl which is equal to zero
wants minimum and uh and uh uh
i'm following this so in a way uh uh
launchbar is basically going as fast as
it can towards pi
in this sense now one thing i did not
mention is that
the kl in the wasserstein sense is
actually a
convex objective so it's called
geodesically convex this is
the equivalent of convexity on curved
spaces
and essentially you will have all the
properties you know
strong convexity implies exponential
convergence
uh a lot of these things are happening
in the same way
but now what's important is that we've
moved from this perspective of
stochastic differential equations
diffusion processes
all the way to optimization and now
we're representing this idea of sampling
as just
optimizing a functional over vasculin
space
using here gradient descent and the
natural question is
can we just unleash the arsenal of
convex optimization that we have to
actually tackle this problem and solve
it faster
so one remark here so now what i've
understood is that
the curve that i was describing now i
even know at each point what its
velocity is and it's minus the gradient
of the kl
at mu t okay so that's the that's the
that
that's how i've described what this
curve uh that i was for
uh moving in vaster stein space this
curve space is the vessel strength space
uh was the negative gradient all right
so of course
now that i have this optimization
perspective this enables me to derive
not only
uh rates of convergence and you know use
all the machinery that allows me to
understand
what structural properties do i need on
pi so that i get fast convergence and
also can i actually use faster
algorithms
so as i said the objective is convex so
just like convex optimization is very uh
developed so this is my go-to book on
convex authorization i'm sure everybody
has their own
the question is can we leverage this
extensive extensive toolbox to
both design and analyze sampling
algorithms okay
so we've talked about gradient descent
from gradient flow
but we could do mirror descent we could
do newton's method we could do proximal
method
we can do uh nestorous acceleration and
you can
think about your favorite optimization
algorithm and try to apply it to that
case
and uh so uh for example so in in in
this year's uh neurops we have a paper
that explores
mere descent and newton's method uh from
this perspective
uh um peter uh uh i mean there's
a bunch of work from berkeley that
explores nesteroff's acceleration
proximal methods are being explored also
as we speak so
all these things is actually a very
natural
uh um playground for people who have
uh some some strength in optimization
[Music]
so the next thing i would like to do is
to try to think beyond diffusions okay
so here
everything we've been doing was uh uh
thinking of a diffusion process which is
what we really implement
as an optimization problem and uh the
two examples that i gave when we're
talking about
newton or mir we're actually also doing
a diffusion and viewing it as an
optimization
can we tackle the optimization directly
right there was a deterministic map
involved when we were pushing uh here so
look again at the second line mu t plus
h
so what i'm doing is i'm just pushing mu
t uh
uh by a deterministic map okay so my
particle xt
is moved to xd plus h using a
deterministic map which is this gradient
okay this gradient this vessels time
gradient and so
now what we want to do is try to know if
we can actually implement this
deterministic push forward map
okay can we do this well the problem is
that if you look at what you can do so
there's the identity that's certainly
fine
h grad v certainly fine but then there's
h grad log d mu t
and that's a problem because you don't
know what the distribution at time t
of your particle is you have just this
one xt that's moving around
let's think about what launchman would
do it would just evolve one one
vector xt and then you don't know what
its distribution is you just know
essentially what its location is
and um and so it's unknown but there's
actually a trick that you can apply
okay so um of course this is usually
when i stuff my uh complicated slide
so i'm gonna go quickly but there's like
a very simple
way to think about how to do this and
the way you can do this is by saying
well
i don't know what this grad log d mu t
is but
i can hope that if i integrate it again
against the kernel k of x y
then this thing will actually be close
to it and that i can actually implement
and in fact you can
all you have to do is to recognize uh
what the form of grad log is and then
apply uh the integration by parts where
you see the minus sign show up
this is really just the integration by
part and
at the end what do you get you get
something which is just an integral d mu
t
and if you want to compute an integral d
mu t then all you need is a bunch of
particles let's say iid particles mu1 to
mu n
so that uh 3 x1 to xn so that when you
average them you have something which is
close to an expectation d mu t
and that's what happens uh uh in this
so-called stein variational gradient
descent sorry i forgot to put
the the the the reference uh uh so this
is definitely not something we came up
with
it's actually a very popular algorithm
right now and uh in style variational
uh gradient descent uh uh what you can
do
is um just evolve a
system of of uh interacting particles
to actually in a completely
deterministic fashion
so that you actually end up with
something that has the right
distribution at the end
okay so here's the idea this is what the
evolution of each of the particles look
like so the j
particle is moving according to this
this thing so it has a bit of a gradient
but then it involves like this gradient
of of the kernel is basically
making all these particles interact
together so
i'm not asking you to to understand this
but uh
what we did in this direction is that so
there's some observation that this can
fail to conversion practice and there's
very little guideline on how to choose
the kernel
and how to analyze this so this can be
viewed also as of course
the way i described it was as being the
gradient flow of the kl but you can
actually view the same algorithm as
being the gradient flow of the chi
square
and in that case you actually can
achieve some some
strong guarantees and you can modify the
algorithm to get better behavior
so this is the second paper that we have
at nerves together with
with uh my group and uh just to show you
how those things behave what it means to
have a deterministic
map so here i'm trying to sample from
this bimodal distribution which is a
mixture of two gaussians
in r2 and this is how the particles
evolve
all right so law gd is the algorithm
that we propose and it's evolving
completely deterministically and
settling uh according to some
distribution that looks like this
mixture of gaussians
whereas svgd is actually moving around
uh
quite a bit okay and actually uh this is
one of the thing that you can identify
from svgd is the fact that you're kind
of keeping some uh
purely rotational component in your in
your uh velocity field
all right so to finish i would like to
give a plug so out of this
uh project uh uh was born a uh simon's
institute program on geometric methods
in optimization and sampling you will
notice the edit distance
uh one with the name of this theme and
uh
and uh so this is a a program uh that
you know peter helped us uh put together
and it's meant to bring people from the
variety of communities that are
uh involved in this uh in this kind of
project so
optimization uh statistics
uh pdes uh pure mathematics calculus of
variations et cetera
it will take place in the fall of 21 and
if you want to know more about it i
encourage you to go see the simon's
institute webpage about it
thank you fantastic thanks philippe
so uh we're actually out of out of time
if there's a quick question
go to the q a otherwise um you're
welcome to go back to
gather town um the link
should be in the chat let me post it
again if you uh
it's just jesse just posted it again uh
in case you weren't here when that was
was posted all right thanks very much
thanks mike and philly